Oh
welcome to Jurassic warehouse
[Music]
this is stegosaur stegosaur is for a
jurassic world exhibition this is our
t-rex she tends to steal the show and
dominate the workshop I can't thinking
one of these things is gonna eat me yeah
Sonny Childers hails from Melbourne and
co-founded creature technology since its
birth in 2006 the company is specialized
in making giant robotic animals and has
ended up as one of the biggest
animatronics companies around the
creature team is made up of movie
special effects artists who needed work
during down periods and their first
project was a live show called Walking
with Dinosaurs that ended up as the
highest-grossing touring event in the
world in 2010
they've been on high demand ever since
making rideable dragons a full-size King
Kong
and cuddlier creations like these giant
stuffed animals for the Sochi Olympics
Vladimir Putin still likes to cuddle the
bunny rabbit on the right we didn't know
where this is gonna go we thought we'd
all go back to filming TV but it grew
out of this one show and we realized
that there was something in this to
bring that sort of film level
animatronics to a live audience this is
the ID Dominus Rex at the moment where
I'm skinning the creature and the girls
are putting in some scales each one of
these creatures takes about a year to
create every detail of the anatomy is
built from scratch including the
eyeballs the hydraulic skeleton and the
life like fabric skin so it's very
similar to a real creature it's got
bones he's got muscles that's got skin
until they work together is that's the
trick really to make the creatures seem
more lifelike the company's coders
program nuanced movement routines
but I'm not here to watch a computer
play with Dinosaurs I'm here to take a
dino out for a spin so this is a Buddha
wreak
so I'm actually controlling the neck of
this Parasaurolophus now this is all
homegrown as hello make that yeah I mean
we built these for our first live show
ten years ago and this is our rusty
workshop model
whenever go yes okay he is designed to
be intuitive and smooth and so you can
take him through his whole range and he
will go where you want to take him to
cover your little pet dinosaur yeah it's
it's a lot of fun there were a couple of
new creations coming to life in the
creature workshop that we weren't
allowed to show secrecy remains
paramount in the vicious world of
animatronics but safe to say though that
the next time a dinosaur giant plush
bear or say an alien greets you at an
amusement park then it came from this
place on the other side of the world
[Music]
you
[Music]